let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
well nancy pelosi had an announcement
yesterday
um here it is listen when we hear people
saying i'm
i'm young and i'm a perfect perfect
specimen instead of addressing the fact
that what 50 000 people were
in fact reported to be infected
yesterday nearly a thousand people
died what are we talking about here
tomorrow
by the way tomorrow come here tomorrow
we're going to be talking about the 25th
amendment but not to take attention away
from the subject we have now
yes uh the 25th amendments they'll be
talking about how to potentially remove
trump from office
with the 25th amendment now trump fired
back about this uh here's the daily wire
report it says president donald trump
and prominent republicans fire back and
speaker of the house nancy pelosi
thursday afternoon if the speaker
suggested that she and democrats will
hold discussions friday about the 25th
amendment presumably to talk over how to
potentially remove
the president from office retweeting a
supporter who suggested that democrats
were already plotting to get trump out
if the president wins re-election
november
trump added that crazy nancy should be
evaluated for her own mental
fitness crazy nancy is the one who
should be under observation
they don't call her crazy for nothing he
tweeted
pelosi announced her event at a weekly
press conference uh so you just heard
that
later on thursday the hill reports
pelosi said that she and representative
jamie raskin
were planning to commission quote to
determine whether a president
is fit for office rasket originally
introduced legislation
2017 which should not get any
legislative action since republicans
control the house at the time
that would create an oversight
commission on presidential capacity
comprised of physicians psychiatrists
and retired public officials like former
presidents and cabinet secretaries
uh congressional leaders will be
responsible for naming members of the um
of the commission uh and then as far as
what this would actually entail like how
would you actually do this well pelosi
has an uphill battle according to the
25th amendment itself which governs
succession if the president's no longer
capable of discharging his duties
the vice president and either a majority
of cabinet members or a majority of both
houses of congress must agree
to depose the president before any
action can be taken to replace him so
um to summarize this of course isn't
really going to happen they aren't going
to depose the president
especially not a few weeks from the
election it's just not not going to
happen
though it wouldn't happen at any other
point either uh this is a political
stunt and a rather stupid
one from the democrats i would think
that there's just no benefit
to them to do this all this can
potentially do
is fire up the right wing base
that's the only potential effect here
and and by the way that's that's what
donald trump needs to win the election
which of course is obvious of course it
needs his base but the point is you know
i
i don't think trump has done a whole lot
uh to appeal to
people in the middle and i don't think
he's done much there really
he's he's playing to his base all the
time exclusively
and uh which i don't think is the best
strategy but that's what he's doing
so if you're the democrats and you're
helping him mobilize the base not a
great
not not a great strategy there either so
that's why i say go for it nancy please
move forward
there's some conservatives that seem to
be upset or angry about this no
go ahead this is great talk about the
25th amendment talk
talk openly about trying to depose the
president
you can't actually do it but if you want
to talk about it
please do number two here's a story that
i've been meaning to hit for a few days
but there's an update to it the story is
is that a school system in virginia
was going to adopt a speech code
banning their teachers from criticizing
in public or
private the school systems critical race
theory program
or it's or it's sorry excuse me it's
racial equity program is what we're
calling it now
uh so they weren't going to be allowed
to criticize it anywhere
on campus or off so here's the update
from the free beacon it says
the loudoun county virginia public
schools district will revise
a proposed speech policy which would
have prohibited teachers from
criticizing the district's racial equity
plan following backlash from the
teachers union
and a washington free beacon report
leadership from the
loudoun education association the
district's largest teachers union
told the free beacon that a school board
member plans to take the speech policy
off
of the upcoming board meeting itinerary
effectively stalling any vote
this change will allow the human
resources department to revise and
review the policy that as currently
written prohibits employees from
criticizing the school district's
commitment to action-oriented equity
practices
in all forms of public and personal
communication um
and then it goes on from there okay so
they're gonna revise and review revise
and review the policy
fine but even so the simple fact
that this policy was ever being
considered
the fact that this is what they want to
do
right it tells you everything you need
to know
and it shows i think it was a i think it
was rod dreier who made this point about
this particular story it shows again why
you know you can't pin all your hopes on
all your hopes for the culture on
winning presidential elections
because every election since i've
since i was born every election that i
can that i was conscious for that i can
remember
uh you always had conservatives saying
we need to elect the republican or
america is over
this is it this is the last election
this is it
every single election we are then we're
hearing that now too
and every single time they say that
right but they say no no
this time it's it wasn't true before
this
i know i said it before but this this
i'm telling you this time
this is the like if we don't win this
election it's over period
but then what happens sometimes
republicans are elected sometimes
they're not
and america's uh cultural march
into insanity continues a pace
regardless it doesn't appear to matter
that much
culturally whether there's a republican
in office or not
in fact if i go back to 2016 before the
election
all of these dire predictions about what
the country would look like if hillary
clinton
was elected and i'm glad that she wasn't
and i do
believe that it would look worse if she
was elected than
than then trump but let's say
you know 2016 before the election
let's say someone from 2020 comes back
from the future and describes what
america looks like
and tells you about the rampaging mobs
and you know critical race theory in the
schools and
gender ideology going crazy just
describes what the culture looks like in
2020
and then says to you who do you think
won hillary or
trump you would probably say oh that
means hillary won
i mean that's that's exactly the america
i expect if hillary wins
nope trump won now i don't um
i don't blame trump for that it's not
really a criticism of trump really
because there's nothing the president
can do about a lot of this stuff
i mean there's really nothing the
president could do for example about
decisions made by local school boards
so this is not an argument
that elections don't matter at all or
that you shouldn't vote or whatever
i'm simply pointing out that the real
fight the real fight for the culture
has almost nothing to do with national
elections
and that we as conservatives continue to
lose the culture
no matter who's in office
and so a certain point i think we need
to realize that we're not going to solve
the problem
just by electing republicans that that
doesn't even get close to it
and elect all the republican presidents
we want
but if we're still doing things like
sending our children into these schools
to be brainwashed for seven hours a day
it's not going to matter the culture's
lost anyway
how many of the republicans who are
saying oh we need we need a republican
in office or
how many of them are willingly sending
their own children
into these government buildings to be
brainwashed into
things like critical race theory and
radical leftist gender ideology
you think trump is gonna you think
trump's gonna save your kid
when you're willingly subjecting your
child to that
at a certain point we have to be willing
to make difficult decisions do hard
things
beyond just voting for a republican
and we have to start thinking long term
also we have to realize that we're
we're not going to halt this march we're
not going to turn things around
i get this all the time when i go and i
say i was just yesterday i was speaking
at grove city college it was a great
event
uh and uh and a lot of great questions
but anytime i'm speaking i always get
this question like what do we do about
this
how do we solve the problem and i mean
it's it's a fine question it's a natural
question to ask but i think the answer
is it's
these are not problems we can solve in a
year or two years or five years
these are generational problems we're
going to solve this problem over the
course of generations
we have to accept the fact that you know
those of us alive today
we are probably not going to witness
much improvement
this is about our children and our
children's children
the left claimed the culture over the
course of generations they didn't do it
in a year
okay they did it in 60 or 70 80 years
so that's what it's gonna be for us we
have to be willing to accept that okay
um this is supposed to be the headline
portion not me rambling on for
15 minutes number three joe biden was
asked about
court packing again and here's what he
had to say about that
they'll know my opinion court packing
when the election is over now look
i know it's a great question we all and
i don't blame you for asking
but you know the moment i answer that
question
the headline in every one of your papers
will be about that
other than other than focusing on what's
happening now
the election has begun there's never
been a court appointment
once an election begun but four million
or so people have
already voted they're denying the
american people
the one shot they have under
constitutional law
to be able to have their input what a
brave man what a brave brave man isn't
he i always tell he's such a brave
bold man no this answer from him is
nonsense
and by the way his answer his answer
about
court packing he says oh i don't want it
to be headline news well it would only
be headline news
if he would support court packing if
he's against it it wouldn't get much
play in the media at all
so the fact that he's that he won't say
because he's worried that he'll make the
headlines
that's just him admitting that he's in
favor of quarterback number four the
number one song on itunes right now
is dreams by fleetwood mac
and no not like a remake or something
this this was uh or a cover or something
this was
released the original song released in
1977
is the number one song on itunes right
now the reason it's number one is
because of a viral tick tock video
that incorporates this song in the video
the video apparently massively viral
very influential
enough to propel this song from from
1977 up the charts
uh so you're wondering what this what's
in this video it must be really really
amazing stuff well here it is
[Music]
yes that's the uh that's it that's the
viral video right there that's uh that's
millions of views on that thing that's a
guy drinking
cranberry juice juice while
skateboarding
okay um you know there's a book out
now uh by ross do thought
doothead do thought i can never
pronounce his name new york times
columnist conservative and he wrote a
book called uh
the the decadent society which i'm
reading right now and i actually find it
i don't read a lot of current affairs
books actually but this one i find to be
pretty compelling and uh he makes the
case that we live in a decadent society
and he doesn't define decadent the way
most people think of it you know for him
a decadent society is one that's sort of
stagnant
uh stale repeating itself kind of
running in place nothing's really
happening
we're just sort of coasting along and um
i i think he's right about that
and he talks about how many many
a lot of evidence of this decadence a
lot of indicators of it and one of them
is in the area of cultural output and so
we bring up like people complain all the
time about all the remakes and
everything and
the number one movies are always like
star wars movies or star wars franchises
go back to the 1970s
and so you talked about that i was we're
not even even
in in the area of pop culture and art
we're not coming up with new stuff we're
just recycling the old
over and over and over again and um
this would be a great example of that
not just that this song 1977 is number
one
but the reason for it is that because of
a video of a guy skateboarding
while drinking cranberry juice all right
now here though
is a unique movie here's this is
something new okay this is some
cultural output we can be proud of
number five finally mel gibson
set to start a movie where he plays a
down on his luck alcoholic santa claus
who's being hunted by a hitman who was
hired by a child who was angry
that he got a lump of coal for christmas
film sounds incredible it looks
incredible too here's a little bit of
the preview watch
[Music]
what's the job i'd like you to kill
santa claus
i've come for your hand fat man
[Music]
you think you're the first think i got
this job because i'm fat and jolly
[Music]
the fat man's got his eye on you kids
yeah i'm in i'm sold personally you
don't have to tell me twice
some people are upset about this because
it's mel gibson and they're you know
they're automatically
offended by anything mel gibson does but
i'm sorry first of all mel gibson is a
great filmmaker and a great actor
uh he i love everybody he has yet to
direct a bad movie every movie he's
directed has been good
uh he's not directing this though but
and and most of
the films that he started have been
pretty good too as far as his personal
issues go
everybody in hollywood has shall we call
personal issues and males have been
more public than others perhaps but that
doesn't make it
worse than what other people have done i
mean roman polanski
child rapist is still making movies
so that's where the bar is set for
scumbag behavior
so yeah you can avoid mel gibson movies
because you find his personal behavior
abhorrent but
then you should also be avoiding a great
many
films because a great many actors and
directors engage in behavior
far more abhorrent than anything mel
gibson
has been accused of doing that is a
movie though that i will be
watching well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt walsh show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content